INDRANIL CHAKRABORTY: Thanks
for coming to the session
on building for Enterprise IoT.
My name is Indranil Chakraborty.
I'm one of the product guy at
Google Cloud Platform focusing
on IoT.
And in this session what
we're going to cover
is we're going to cover
some of the key products
and services which Google has
for building IoT solution, some
of the key challenges
that we've seen
and we've heard from
developers and partners,
and how Google thinks about
addressing those challenges.
And at the end we'll
have a short demo.
So let's get started.
There you go.
So imagine never being
stuck looking for parking.
Imagine if every parking
lot, every parking space,
has a sensor embedded
in the space which
can data mine whether that
space is occupied or not.
And it sends its
data to Cloud, so
that as you are driving,
looking for parking
in a city like Amsterdam,
or any other city,
you know exactly
where the parking
lot, what space is open, and
your car goes and parks there.
Now imagine if in
the US it is believed
that there are around 800
million parking spaces.
Imagine if all those spaces
have sensors embedded.
Imagine the amount of data
that we generated in order
for us to figure out which
of the spaces is available,
and send the data down to you,
the applications such as Google
Maps.
Let's take some more examples.
At Google we've used deep
learning-- machine learning--
to reduce the amount of energy
needed for cooling data centers
by almost 40%.
So imagine if you can optimize
the power consumption in all
the commercial buildings by
applying the same principle.
So where you collect
real-time data
from your edge [INAUDIBLE],,
from your coolers,
from ambient temperatures,
humidity, lights, coolers,
and all the data, and you
build machine-learning models
using historical data
over time, and then you
apply those predictions
based on these models
to optimize for your
cloud consumption
in commercial building.
So such applications like this
could be really revolutionary.
And we seeing some
patterns in the industry
on some of the customers
building such applications
as well.
Utilities is another example.
Utility providers have been
installing smart meters
over the last couple of years.
And now, by connecting
the smart meters to Cloud,
they can get a real-time view
of power consumption in a city,
and also break it down by
neighborhoods within a city
as well.
Now they can compare the
real-time demand with forecast,
and they can balance the power
distribution real time as well.
So these are some of the
revolutionary applications
we see when you use the sensor
data and our cloud platform
to really build a compelling
enterprise application.
And very soon cities
will have millions
of smart meters sending energy
data, energy reading real time.
So we believe that IoT
is at an inflection point
where we expect
significant growth
over the next couple of years.
In fact, if you look
at the projection,
while mobile phones growth
has been much bigger
than personal computers,
a much higher growth wave
is expected for IoT.
Depending on the
analyst report you read,
it is estimated that around 20
billion to 30 billion devices
will be connected
to internet by 2020.
While each of
these devices might
send a few hundreds of
bytes every few seconds,
or for minutes, or
an hour, cumulative
that's a massive
amount of data which
will be generated by
these billions of devices
connected to internet.
So this creates a
couple of challenges.
One is as you think about
building IoT solution,
one of the key
challenge is security.
How do you make sure that
all these devices that
are connected are secured,
they are not compromised;
and also the data which is
being generated by these devices
are securely stored
on cloud or on prem?
Second is scale.
So when you have
millions or even
billions of devices
connected to cloud,
how do you ensure that we can
build the application that
can ingest this
massive influx of data,
and store it cost effectively?
And how do you
make sure that when
you have these
millions of devices,
that all these devices have
the right firmware version;
they have the right security
patches as well, so you're not
worried about fragmentation in
your fleet of deployed devices?
And then finally,
when you have data,
what do you do with the data?
What do you do with
the mass of data?
How do you get
actionable insights
so that you can really use
it to optimize your business
processes, or to glean
specific insights which
will help in your business?
So we've been working hard
over the last couple of years
to really make it easier for
developers to build the IoT
solution on Google Cloud
that is secure, scalable, as
well as you can get
actionable insight as well.
I think you all know that Google
has around seven products--
consumer products-- that there
are more than 1 billion users--
active users-- that are
engaging with these products.
So as part of our mission
to organize the world's
information, we've been
working with and dealing
with massive scale of data, big
data, for over a decade now.
And in the process of
handling this scale of data,
we've also built one of
the world's best computer
infrastructure across
hardware, software, networking,
and operations.
We built an infrastructure
such that for developers it's
just one computer, and it's
not a collection of computers.
And developers, you just write
code, and write applications,
and we take care of running them
across different data centers,
or scaling them across different
infrastructures as well.
In addition to our data
center infrastructure,
we've also been working hard in
building up our data management
and technical stack as well.
So you've heard about
Pub/Sub, BigQuery, Bigtable.
Everything that Google has
built which we use internally
for our own development, and
are used by internal developers,
are in the process of
being externalized.
So recently you've heard about
TensorFlow, which we have also
packaged as Cloud ML.
Spanner is another example.
So we believe that we have the
industry-leading services when
it comes to data analytics
and machine learning.
And many of our developers,
partners, and enterprise
customers have been leveraging
these cloud platform
services to build
enterprise applications.
But when it comes to IoT, the
same developers and partners
have asked before
that it's great
that you have the
services, but how
do we connect our
devices to Google Cloud,
and how do we manage those
devices to Google Cloud
so that we can start to benefit
from the machine learning
and data analytics
services that you have?
So last month, we're
pretty excited that we
announced a product
called Cloud IoT Core.
It's a new service on
Google Cloud Platform,
with the singular
goal of making it
really easy for developers
to build enterprise IoT
applications.
What is Cloud IoT Core?
It's a fully managed service
to securely connect and manage
your devices on
Google Cloud Platform.
So what we've done
is first we have
added support for the industry
standard protocol MQQT.
As we talked to
partners and developers,
we realized that many
of these devices,
existing devices which
are already applied,
or even new devices,
they use MQQT
for machine-to-machine and even
machine-to-Cloud messaging.
So with Cloud IoT
Core, you can securely
connect your device
using TLS, and then
use MQQT messaging protocol
for sending telemetry
to Google Cloud.
The second key thing
of Cloud IoT Core,
is we scale internally.
Whether you're connecting
one device or you scale up
to millions of
device, you don't have
to worry about provisioning a
new node, or a new instance,
or a new infrastructure.
We scale internally.
And we can handle millions
or even billions of devices
as you scale up or scale down.
And we also tightly
integrated this
with Pub/Sub, which
allows you to get
a central view of your
globally disposed devices.
I'm going to talk
a little bit more
about how that works
in a few minutes.
We've also added functionality--
some key functionalities--
for device management.
So you can individually
configure your device
to make sure that each device
is authenticated separately.
So we have support
for per device,
asymmetric keys-based
authentication using JSON Web
Token.
And this ensures
that this in fact
limits the surface
area of attack.
So even if a public key or a
private key is compromised,
it will only affect that
particular device, not
the rest of your fleet.
So we've added
per-device authentication
as part of a device management
capability with Cloud IoT Core.
With Cloud IoT Core
you can also send
a configuration and updates
to your devices from the cloud
as well.
You can control your
devices from Google Cloud.
And you can even control access
to users to a set of devices,
or a group or devices,
using Cloud IAM.
Access can be granted at a
project level on Google Cloud,
or at a registry level.
If you have a signed in
Cloud IAM at a project level,
then all the
registries by default
will inherit those roles.
But you can refine it at
individual or registry level
as well.
And finally, we have
a rich set of APIs
for you to build your compelling
enterprise application
on top of Cloud IoT Core.
So we've announced this last
month as a private beta.
And we're getting interesting,
good feedback from our partners
and developers.
And we plan to make it available
more broadly in the next couple
of months.
So I want to spend just
a little bit of time
on the resource model
for device management
capability on Cloud IoT Core.
So let's say if you are
a device manufacturer,
and you have 10 different
categories of devices,
you will go to Google Cloud,
and you have a project.
Under project you can create
10 different registries,
each for your each of
your device category.
And registry essentially
is a collection of devices.
So you can create for each
category one registry,
and under each registry you
can register as many devices
as you want.
You can have millions of
devices under each registry.
And a device, when
you register a device,
is essentially a
logical representation
of your physical device.
So we store the
credential for the device.
So when you add a device,
or you register a device
to your registry, you have to
add the public key, which will
be used for authentication.
We also store the configuration.
And eventually we'll
add states as well.
So it's an exact representation
of your physical device
on the cloud side.
So you can have multiple
registries per project.
And each registry, you can
register as many devices
as you want.
So this really gives
you the ability
to manage a massive
scale of devices,
and you can group them based on
your, say, specific use case.
You can assign,
like as I mentioned,
a certain access control
at a registry level.
So for example, you can
create a Cloud IAM provision,
Cloud IAM role called
provisioner at a registry.
So all the users which
belong to that role
will only be able to add or edit
device, but not remove or add
new registry.
So you have this granular
level of access control
that you can provide
at registry level.
And as we were
building this product,
and releasing this
product, we realized,
and we understand that both
developers and enterprise
partners would want to first
build some quick prototype
to wet their feet before they
do full-scale development.
So we have a simple UI as well,
as part of Cloud IoT Core,
for management and
monitoring of devices.
So what we see here is if you
go to the Core Cloud console,
on the dropdown menu there
will be a section for IoT Core.
If you select,
click on IoT Core,
you would see all the
registries that has been already
added by you previously.
You can also create
a new registry,
and I'll show you the demo
later down in my session.
So the top one shows a
list of all the registries
which has been added.
You can assign the ID to
it you can select a region
where you want all the
devices, register that device,
to have it stored as metadata.
And it shows the
different protocols
that registry devices support.
One interesting thing about
my IoT Core and registry
is you can assign a Pub/Sub
topic to a registry.
What that means
is all the device
data which belongs to that
registry would be published
to that Pub/Sub topic.
So while each
individual device will
be sent in publishing as
data on a particular topic,
but it will get aggregated and
published at a Pub/Sub topic,
so you can get a real global
view of all the devices
by consuming data from
Pub/Sub topic as well.
And when you select
on the registry on UI,
you can get a list
of devices that are
registered in that registry.
And you can see some you have
simple status, such as there's
enable, disable, what was
the last message received
by that particular device.
So you can do some simple
monitoring as well.
And if you go drill
down even more,
you can select on the
particular device,
and get some
additional information
about that particular
device as well.
So it's a simple way
for you to get started
where you can create some
registry, and add some devices,
and start playing
with the product,
and really start connecting
the data to build
a simple application.
As we launch IoT
Core, we have also
announced partnership agreement
with some of our leading device
manufacturers and
software vendors
as well, such as Intel,
Microchip, NXP, Sierra
Wireless, Arm.
All these hardware
partners have agreed
to support Cloud IoT Core.
And we're working very
closely with these partners
to make it really
easy for developers
to have these partner
devices seamlessly
connect to Cloud IoT Core.
So imagine, the way to work
is if you purchase a device
from NXP, it will have a
very simple instruction
to show you how to connect
that device to Cloud IoT Core.
In fact, moving forward,
we are working hard
with these partners so
that when you buy a device,
and it boots up, it
will just automatically
connect to Cloud IoT Core.
And in fact, thanks to some of
our partners, such as Mongoose,
you can connect any
microcontroller.
This is a tiny MCU device
built by Expressif.
It's an ESP8266.
You can have this
tiny device directly
connect to Cloud
IoT Core as well.
So you can set up
a TLS connection
using the software
made by Mongoose OS,
and their sample
code, which shows you
how you can connect
these devices directly
to Cloud IoT Core.
They have the ability
to generate public key,
so you can authenticate
each of these devices
individually, and
in a secure way.
So we're pretty
excited about this.
And so we'll continue
to work hard with a lot
of our new partners as well.
So you will hear a lot more
about our partner ecosystem
going forward.
And I would really encourage
you guys to visit our site
cloud.google.com/iot/partners.
So see the list of devices,
software partners with whom we
have agreement for
Cloud IoT Core.
And we're working with
a lot more of them,
so you'll hear a lot
more down the road.
So I talked about
securely connecting
your device, and some
aspects of how you can
manage those devices on cloud.
But once you have
connected the device,
how do you ingest the
massive amount of data
from your millions or
billions of devices?
And Pub/Sub is great for that.
What Pub/Sub allows you to
do is a couple of key things.
One is a global service.
So you may have devices
dispersed across the globe.
But with Pub/Sub, you can get
a central view of all the data
that has been published
across all these devices.
What Pub/Sub also has is it
has durable persistent message.
So it promises that the
message from a device
is stored until acknowledgement,
or a return message
is sent back to the device.
So this makes a
lot of sense when
you have a use case where you
don't want to-- particularly
for medical devices-- where you
don't want to lose any data.
Pub/Sub is a great way to sort
of route the data downwards.
And Pub/Sub also helps us to
decouple your upstream devices
from a downstream application.
Because with Pub/Sub,
you can continue
to iterate on your
application which
is consuming the data without
needing to change or update
your upstream devices.
And you can, for example,
have Cloud Function consume,
subscribe to a
topic from Pub/Sub,
which you can use to
build some simple rules.
You can use Cloud Dataflow for
some complex event processing.
Or even you can use an
existing ETL pipeline
to consume the data
which has been generated
by all these devices
connected to Cloud IoT Core
through Pub/Sub.
So with Cloud IoT Core and
Pub/Sub, and the conjunction
of this, you can securely
connect your devices,
but also ingest
massive amount of data
without worrying
about provisioning
or creating new infrastructure.
So once you've
connected and ingested,
next step is what do
you do with the data?
So here I've listed
some key examples
of the different services,
existing cloud services, which
you can use for
storage and analysis.
So BigQuery is great
for calibrating,
and the understanding
of the data.
So you can have hundreds of
billions of rows of data,
and you can do some quick
query to really understand
what are the other
typical trends you're
seeing on the data.
You can then use Dataflow
to clean up the data
and build some simple models.
You can create some
simple regression
models using Dataflow.
And then further down, you can
then use machine learning--
Cloud ML-- to create, to
train, to intensive flow model,
using the data which you
have generated and stored
on BigQuery, or even Bigtable.
So we have all these services--
to name a few, BigQuery,
Dataflow, Big Data
Lab, and the Cloud ML--
for once you've
gathered the data,
to glean insights and
build models, train
models on those data as well.
So here's a view of how
we see the entire IoT
platform as you think about
building IoT solution on Google
Cloud.
So you have Cloud
IoT Core, which
sits between the devices
and Google Cloud,
for you to securely connect
and manage your data.
The data gets
published to Pub/Sub.
And from there you can
write some simple rules
using Cloud Function.
For example, you
can say every time
the median temperature,
or the temperature
goes above 90 degrees, I
want to turn on the fan.
So you can write some simple
rules using Cloud Function,
and you can send command
back to your devices
using Cloud IoT Core.
Or you can use Dataflow for
doing some complex event
processing as well.
And once you have
cleaned up the data
based on using
Dataflow jobs, you
can store it in
BigQuery or Bigtable
for further analysis
and report generation.
Then you can use Cloud
ML, as I mentioned,
to build some machine
learning models, train models.
And then use prediction--
Cloud ML predictions--
to act on the data
and send some relevant commands
back to the devices as well.
So overall, on the
Cloud side I talked
about how you can connect to
your devices to Google Cloud
ingest them at scale
without worrying about
whether it's a few devices
or millions of devices
without needing to provision
any infrastructure.
And you can use an
existing service,
such as Cloud ML, and
BigQuery, and Datalab
for data analysis and storage.
I want to spend
some time on how we
can take care of security,
scale and insights at the edge
itself.
And we have Android
Things, which
is a fully managed operating
system for devices and edge
gateways.
So Android Things essentially
is Android operating system
that is optimized to
run on IoT devices.
Now what does that mean?
So what we have done is
we have taken the Android,
the stock Android, and we
have removed the components
which is not relevant to IoT.
For example we have removed all
the notification, the system
uIPs, user applications; and
then added some specific IoT
components, such as Peripheral
I/O and device driver support.
So you can connect additional
component to your devices,
and then run Android
Things on them as well.
And some of the key things which
you get with Android Things
is number one, if you
want to build scale--
so if you want to build
some quick prototype for all
the Android
developers out there--
you can use a familiar
Android ecosystem,
such as the Android
SDK, the Android Studio,
to build those applications,
compile it into APK,
and run it on Android Things.
You can even use
some existing APK
that you have built for
Android mobile phone
and port it into
Android things as well.
So this really makes
it, for the developer,
to really have built quick
prototypes on the device
by using the familiar
Android ecosystem.
And we already have more than
$2 billion monthly active phones
and tablets which
are running Android.
And now we're extending
it to IoT as well.
Second is with Android Things
we have used Android Things
for security on
the device as well.
So the great thing
about Android Things
is since it leverages
the key component
of security for Android--
so it has a secure boot.
The applications are signed.
And Google manages the former
version of Android Things.
So we will make sure that
all the Android Things
devices has the latest firmware,
has the right security patches,
so that none of them
can be compromised.
Of course, in cases where
the enterprise customer
or developers want
more control in terms
of when that patch
should be deployed,
that is available as well.
And Android Things, I'll talk
more about designer things,
also work seamlessly
with Cloud IoT Core.
And we are working harder
to make this integration
much more simpler.
So that was on the software
side of Android Things.
On the hardware layer,
we're working hard
to remove the complexity
of building a device.
So we're working
with silicon partners
to certify their SOM,
essentially a system on module.
So SOM will come with
your CPU, memory, storage,
and connectivity.
And all the components
to run our Android things
are already built in.
So you can start using
the certified devices
to add it to your base board,
and add necessary components
as you feel.
And since the SOM is
already certified,
you don't have to go through
the certification process
separately.
For enterprise
customers, we already
have partners such as
NXP, Intel, Qualcomm,
who are already building
certified SOM which
runs Android Things.
So you can just take
those components
and start testing Android Things
for your specific use case.
And finally, the last
layer for Android things
is really the services.
So we want to make sure
that with Android Things
you can leverage
the existing Google
services as well, such as
location services, assistance
service, Chromecast
cast service, as well
as our new services,
such as TensorFlow.
So great thing about
Android is number one,
it seamlessly work
with Cloud IoT.
So if you have Android Things
device, it is very easy for you
to connect those
device to Cloud IoT
and start leveraging the
cloud platform for it.
And secondly, Android
Things can use TensorFlow.
You can use TensorFlow
on Android Things
to run machine learning
model locally on the device.
So this works in the use
case where latency matters,
or you don't want to send
every information to the cloud.
You can run your TensorFlow
model locally at the edge,
and get the same
level of insights
as you would do with Cloud.
And I'll talk more, give
some specific example.
So let's take a
specific example.
Let's say you want
to check the quality
control of your product.
You're making a
pizza, and you want
to make sure that
every pizza that's
been made in an assembly line
is meeting your quality bar.
There's no template, so you
can use machine learning
to look at the shape of
the pizza that comes up,
the color, some of the texture,
the temperature, and all
of that, and really
figure out which one
is meeting your quality bar.
So in this case,
what you would do
is you'll have a camera
which is capturing
the pictures of the pizza
as it's being manufactured.
And you will have
trained a model on Cloud
which automatically can
detect whether a pizza is
meeting your bar or not.
And then you can push
that TensorFlow model
into the camera which is
running Android Things.
So as the camera is
capturing the picture of each
of those pizza, it is locally
running the trained model
to see if it is really
meets your quality bar,
or should it be remade,
or should it be rejected.
And then over time, you
can send part of the feed
to Cloud through Cloud IoT
Core so that you can constantly
retrain and update
that model, and then
download the model back
into the local device
for local processing.
So this kind of example
with Android Things
and with Cloud IoT,
as you can see,
you not only get the benefit
of the massive infrastructure
on Cloud for training purposes,
for training your model,
but you can also,
where it makes sense,
you can run some of the
processing locally as well.
And with Android Things, it
can build APK applications
where you can do some
filtration, or some edge
processing on the device,
and send the rest of the data
to the cloud for
further analysis.
So when you think about IoT,
Android Things connecting
to IoT, there are a couple of
steps which needs to happen.
So in this case, when we'll
create a cloud project,
you'd have to enable
the Cloud IoT API.
And Android Things
has a key store,
where the private key
is protected and stored,
so you cannot tamper with it.
But you can extract the public
key from the Android Things
key store.
And then you take
that public key,
and you register that
device with that public key,
with Cloud IoT Core.
And you are, for registration
you can use CLIs or command
line tools which we have, or
even you can use some of the UI
as well.
And once you've
registered the device,
then it's really the
third step is really
to configure your APK to send
MQQT messages to Cloud IoT
Core.
And we have a sample, which
is already posted on GitHub.
You can look it up on
gitup.com/androidthings.
I really encourage you
guys to search for it.
And there's a simple
application sample code
which you can use to build
an APK for [INAUDIBLE] device
which will connect
to Cloud IoT Core,
and start sending database
from your device to Cloud.
And you can even look at some
of the TensorFlow pieces well.
So with Android
Things on the edge,
and with Cloud IoT
Core on the cloud
side for secure connection
and device management,
you can really start
thinking about building
really compelling application
for enterprise-specific use
cases.
So let me spend some
time on some quick demos.
So if we switch to the computer.
Great.
So this is our cloud, Google
Cloud platform console.
And if you go to
the menu bar, there
will be a section
called IoT Core.
If you select on
that, what happens
is you would see a list of all
the registries that has already
been added and created before.
So if you want to
start a new registry,
you go to Cloud
IoT Cloud Console.
You just click that.
Let me expand it
so you can see it.
Let's say I create a
new registry-- say,
Amsterdam Session.
You can select a
region where you
want the registry and
all the device metadata
for the registry to restore.
Here we select a
pops-up topic where
all the data from all
the devices registered
to this registry will
be eventually published.
So for now I'll just select one.
And then you create.
Once you do that, you have
created a new registry
called Amsterdam Session.
And then after that, you
can add a device as well.
So every physical
device which you
want to connect to
Cloud IoT Core you
have to register the
device into a registry.
And then once the
device connects,
we will use that information
which you have passed
to authenticate the device.
So when you add a device, you
can give any device ID name
here.
By default, it will be enabled,
unless you want to disable it.
And as I've mentioned,
for authentication
we use per-device
private public key pair.
And we support two
crypto algorithms.
So we support RSA
as well as ECC.
So you can choose which crypto
algorithm you want to use.
And assuming you have
the private key, either
you can generate separately,
or you have it stored.
You can extend the public key,
and add it here, and then just
add, add and
register the device.
You can register up to three
public keys per device.
You can also specify an expiry.
By default we won't
expire the public key.
But if you'd put
an expiry, then we
will not use a public
key for authentication.
So let me show you.
Since I've added a session, if
I go to a new registry which
I have created before called
Group Register, what I see
is there are all these devices,
which I've registered before.
And they're all
in disabled state.
So what I've done is you
think about the use case where
if you have a large
amount of devices which
you want to connect to cloud.
So when you register
the device, by default
you would register
them as disabled.
And when you know that the
devices has been installed
and has been
provisioned, then you
can enable it on the
Cloud side so they
can start connecting
to Cloud IoT Core
and start sending data.
So by default all of
them are disabled here.
And the device ID
here, by the way,
is just the MAC address
we have used here.
So as I mentioned, we
have a rich set of APIs
which you can use for
registering your devices.
You can use the UI, but
you can also have the APIs.
So I have a mobile app here.
And right now what it does is
it connects to Cloud IoT Core,
the rest API on IoT Core.
And what I'll do is I will say
I've looked at the devices.
They're ready to go.
So I want to enable
all these devices
so they can start connecting
and start sending data.
So I have an app here
which connects to Cloud IoT
Core using the rest API.
And I'll just say
enable devices.
And you would see that the
devices starts to get enabled.
And as it's enabled, as the
device starts to connect,
we can actually go
to each of the device
and see when was the last
time we saw a message.
So this is a simple way of
batch registering your devices.
And then when you're ready
for the devices to connect,
you can enable these
devices as well.
Now the other thing I want to
show you is what we have done
is we have taken a large number
of Raspberry Pi devices, which
has a humidity
sensor, a temperature
sensor, a luminosity sensor,
and a pressure and motion sensor
as well.
And we have deployed it
across our Google Office
in Mountain View,
in San Francisco,
and in some of the
other offices as well.
And what we're
doing with those is
we are collecting data
on a regular basis.
All these devices are
sending data per second,
or sometimes a couple
of times a second.
And we have created a dashboard.
So this registry,
weather station,
has a list of all the
devices which are registered.
And if I select, let's
say, the top device here,
it'll show you that the
device has been lost.
It's recently
published data at 2:38.
And there was an error.
Sometimes when there are
errors, we can see that as well.
You see the public key here.
You can also add an
additional public key.
So you can drill
down to each device
and see the status, when
was the last message sent,
so you know whether the device
is actually functioning or not.
But if you want to
actually see the data,
you can pull the data
from Pub/Sub topic.
The other interesting
thing about the device
is when you go to this section,
you can quickly sort of eyeball
and see, all right, this device
has sent data through the DL,
but the second device hasn't
sent any data since May 16th.
So something is off there.
So you can sort of
drill down and look
at the logs, or sort of start
investigating and debugging it
as well.
We also have on the
UI the ability for you
to send a configuration
update as well.
So let me take a
quick look here.
And we have a demo
we have created.
There are a couple of devices
which are registered here.
So I can just go to [INAUDIBLE].
This is a relay device which is
sitting in Mountain View now.
But what I can do is I can
look at the history of all
the configuration updates
which was sent from the cloud
to the device.
So what it does is if you send
a message to it saying fan
on colon true or false,
it'll turn on or off
based on what message you
send it them, to the relay.
So you can see all the messages
which were sent last month.
You click on it.
You can actually see what
was sent to the device.
So it's a very
simple JSON object
which says fan on equal to
false, or true in that way.
And what you can
do here from UI is
if you want to send a
message to the device,
you can select, just say,
text, and you say fan on.
I can change it
to true and send.
It'll send it.
And it'll automatically update
it here, listed here as well.
And when we get an
acknowledgment back
from the device you would
see it in the device details.
So this is still waiting
for an acknowledgement,
because the device is in
[INAUDIBLE],, and it's not up.
But you will get to see the
last time when the device sent
an acknowledgment back based on
the configuration update which
was sent.
So it's a simple UI tool for
you to create a quick registry,
build some quick prototypes,
send commands to the devices.
You can also receive
data as well.
So another thing
we have is this is
a dashboard which we have
built using Cloud IoT Core.
So we have all these devices
which are, as I mentioned,
deployed across Google offices.
And this is collecting
the data real time.
So if I go to a specific device,
I can just look at it here.
And as you can see,
I'm getting messages
pretty much every second, or
every two seconds in updates.
So it has the temperature,
humidity, light,
and pressure data.
And you can collect all
this data real time.
You can create some
simple dashboard.
And we are storing
it in BigQuery,
so you can do some
subsequent analysis
based on this data as well.
So to just wrap it up, can
we go back to the slides?
Perfect.
So we talked about
three key things.
One is on the Cloud side,
with Cloud IoT Core,
you can now securely connect
and manage your fleet of devices
so that you can collect
data from your devices
and start using our
data analytics ingestion
and storage and machine learning
capabilities on this data.
And we also have Android Things
for edge device, which you can
get the same level of security.
You can run some
local TensorFlow
to get insights at the edge.
And you can also manage
all these devices at scale,
because Google takes
care of the former update
and former version as well.
Now the Android Things work
seamlessly with Cloud IoT Core.
But you can connect
to any device.
It doesn't have to
run Android Things.
You can connect any device
which is running either DBN,
or some other operating
former version.
As long as you can
connect, you can
use MQQT to connect to Cloud IoT
Core and start sending message.
So as the example I gave
you is this small MCU, which
is not running Android
Things, but it runs a small OS
by Mongoose.
It runs and supports
MQQT in TLS,
and so it can connect
to Cloud IoT Core,
and start sending the
messages there as well.
So a couple of
quick, next things,
is we have some help links.
So for Android
Things, you can go
to developer.android.com/things.
For IoT Core, it's
cloud.google.com/iot-core.
IoT Core is in
private beta, so you
have to request access
to start using it.
And we review our
access request,
and we were looking at
it, and we grant access
based on your use case.
We will, over the
next couple of months,
make it more broadly available
so you can start using it.
But if you want to
use, I'll encourage
you guys to go to the
site and request access
so you can start
using it as well.
And there's a developer
community site as well.
That's it.
So thanks.
And if you have questions, do
we have time for questions?
We have some time?
OK.
I can take one or two
questions in two minutes.
Otherwise I'll be
standing outside
if you have more questions.
AUDIENCE: Will you also
connect to older IoT platforms?
INDRANIL CHAKRABORTY: The
question is, would you
connect to other IoT platforms?
So if the use case is that you
have your devices connecting
to Cloud IoT Core, because we
publish our data to Pub/Sub,
you can consume that
data, and you can send it
to other IoT platform as well.
So you can send it to your
own, in-built IoT solution,
or you can send it to some
other public cloud provider.
But if your question is around
if I have my own IoT solution,
IoT platform, and how
do I send the data,
you could still use it using
cloud-to-cloud adapter.
So you can directly
connect to Pub/Sub,
or you can send it
via MQQT to IoT Core.
So it should be able to support
other platforms as well.
OK.
Thanks for coming.
And if you have more questions,
I will be standing outside.
Thank you.